nous connaissons tous kérékou
aujourd'hui il vient d'avoir 20 ans ce
compte est toujours aussi charmant
humaniste et donc les enfants
d'aujourd'hui doivent absolument le
découvrir et les enfants d'hier doivent
absolument le voir ou le revoir sur
grand écran
souvenez vous un peu l'histoire à peine
sorti du ventre de sa mère il parlait
court plus vite que le commun des
mortels mais il est aussi très malin et
il incarne le courage et la persévérance
dans ce film la frontière entre le bien
et le mal n'est pas si évidente mais
c'est ça le message fondamental du film
la source de la méchanceté est bien
souvent la souffrance et un retour en
arrière est possible mais pour ça il
faut bien sûr aller à la rencontre de
l'autre et le comprendre pour sublimer
ce compte
michel ocelot a utilisé le dessin
traditionnel pain sur papier la faune et
la flore y sont très riches
d'ailleurs les décors sont ouvertement
inspiré du douanier rousseau la musique
composée par youssou ndour ce film peut
être vu à partir de 4 ans mais certaines
scènes sont impressionnantes pour les
plus jeunes comme les apparitions
théâtrales de la sorcière ou les animaux
sauvages
je conseille donc ce film pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans retrouvez
kirikou et la sorcière au cinéma le
grenier à sel
[Musique]